the mainstream media being accused of a
major double standard over its covet
coverage outlets facing criticism for
hardly mentioning barack obama's 60th
birthday party this weekend in martha's
vineyard
where leaked photos show the former
president dancing without a mask among a
celebrity-filled crowd one new york
times writer facing backlash for
how she is defending these scaled down
celebration
other people said you know this is
really being overblown
they're following all the safety
precautions people are going to sporting
events that are bigger than this
this is going to be safe this is a
sophisticated vaccinated crowd
and and this is just about optics it's
not about safety
the press taking a different approach
when it comes to gop governors by
directly blaming them for the spread of
the new
coronavirus strength greg abbott
is in a race to be the worst possible
governor in the country
and if the only one he's got competition
with right now is governor desantis of
florida
instead of the delta variant why not
call it the desantis variant
in florida we have a governor more
interested in playing politics than
saving lives
the desantis variant so i don't care
i'm glad that the president had a
birthday party i think it's good for him
if you're vaccinated you want to have a
party and you invite people to your
house like
that's fine he's not in charge of
anybody he's not telling anybody what to
do but
greg was this like the most marie
antoinette thing we have seen since
gavin newsom went to the french laundry
i uh i just want to know where did they
scale
stuff back like today harry david didn't
come oh yes they had
instead of uh three kardashians they
said we're putting the limit on two
and there's going to be no bottle
service at the helipad that was it
that was it but i'm wit you know look
obama just told the rest of america
don't just live your life live your best
life
that's what he's telling you goes i am
having a massive birthday party
i'm telling you half the people there he
didn't even know right but he was
he wasn't going to change anything but
now he's got to do something else
because the problem with him is he had a
massive bash
while uh the unvaccinated rates in the
in the cities among blacks
remains near 70 and he is somebody who
could change that
so while you're done with the party why
don't you do something
why don't you create some kind of free
speaking tour right invite some of your
famous friends
and the only entrance fee is that when
you're in line you get
vaccinated he could go to every every
inner city whether you want to do
manhattan or oakland dc atlanta detroit
harlem bronx whatever
the impact would be incredible he could
really do something
uh but instead you know he's gonna have
a party as for these other idiots
uh um you know it was great to watch
acosta think that that was clever
what if we call it the uh what was the
the desantis it was like that like he
took one from column a
and another thing from column b and he
put it together and he thought that's
really edgy
and then you have that dumb rod from the
mornings doing the same thing can't
remember her name
and also well as soon as you heard annie
carney of the new york times basically
trying to protect celebrities from any
scorn
by saying but they're sophisticated and
it's a sophisticated crowd
yeah not like not like those people that
went on a motorcycle ride in surges
right let's be clear about who we're
talking about here these are
sophisticated people
vaccinated people the only thing i
disagree with greg is
i'm happy that president obama is living
his best life but he's not encouraging
others to live their best but that's
what i'm saying by his
own actions he is he is by his actions
but by his political party's words and
by his political ideology they are
blatantly saying there are two classes
of people in this world danny you laid
it out perfectly
look this is a sequel to a very bad
movie this is covid part two the delta
variant
we saw it all through the first version
as you mentioned gavin newsom going to
the french laundry
we now have muriel bowser officiating
web weddings mask-less while instituting
a mask mandate in in dc and here we have
them talking about
masking our children in schools in this
coming school year
while president obama has a party with
four to five hundred people largely
maskless
great live your best life may we live
our best life as well
yeah what do you think of all this i
want to party
i think everybody should be living their
lives normally i think that they should
be moving on uh with whether it's
sturgis or whether it's president obama
having a party
the problem is that the white house the
cdc
democratic governors around the country
are still have they still have a boot on
people's livelihoods because they're
so threatening that if you don't do this
or if you don't do this
we're going to shut your business down
or we're going to implement a mandate on
you and the idea that they they do want
to put two-year-olds
and children in school in mass for hours
on end without any real data to back up
that it actually works
by the way i think is really appalling
and when you look at the standard the
media has
a sophisticated vaccinated crowd
uh this is a class war you know it's
nancy pelosi wants hairdressers to work
in california when you're doing her hair
the dj at the obama party can dj for a
large group of 500 people
during covid as long as he's working for
president obama for a party
but if you're a dj who wants to do a
regular italian wedding in new jersey
well there's going to be restrictions on
you and we're not going to allow you to
work
and the bottom line is that this is
still america and americans are not
subjects they are citizens and they
certainly are not peasants
who are pla are supposed to play by a
separate set of rules
then the elitist ruling class in
washington or in hollywood and that's
exactly what this is because there are
there are real consequences for working
people who are worried about losing
their job
again as a result of what people like
this and the decisions that they are
making for their lives jessica do you
think president obama
could do something more in terms of
helping black americans
become more comfortable getting the
vaccine i think honestly all of us could
always do something more that's an
opportunity i like greg's idea i mean
i'm
not a black american but i would get
vaccinated a second time if it meant
that i could go see barack obama speak
um we can all do more and this was a big
conversation early on in the pandemic
when the vaccine was coming about how
the people that we really need to be out
there talking about it
for black and brown communities are are
people that matter to those communities
so
jay-z and beyonce and lebron james and
what a big deal it was when
nba players you know had one shot and
not the second shot and ended up in
protocols and
it's confusing i mean this is a
confusing disease and you say it's a
terrible
sequel the delta variant it's really
terrible though i mean when
i don't i'm not calling it the desantis
strain but there are thousands and
thousands and thousands of people are
now hospitalized in florida
and a lot of them children and this is
with 20 of the new cases of delta
are amongst children and that's why it's
so important that adults are getting
vaccinated that you do your part and you
do that to protect your children who are
not
approved to have the vaccine yet so i'm
all for a full court press
on the vaccination front but i do agree
if he wants to have a party
he should have it it was outside where
we know that it doesn't get passed it
was sturgis
and also outside but if you watch i
don't know if anyone watched bill maher
last weekend but he shouted out
lollapalooza which was also a huge
violation a hundred thousand people and
i appreciate that from the liberal side
call out the big party in chicago don't
just call out a motorcycle rally
and how about we don't call anybody and
let people make their own decisions
about how they want to manage their own
risks but
because they are taking a toll on first
of all our health care system i hear
that from conservatives all the time i
don't want to pay for your decisions
we're paying for what's going on in
these icus we are every single one of
them people are on ventilators
you know we've been doing that for 40 50
years with cigarettes
and obesity yeah but you know what i
think
it would be good to hear governor
desantis respond to what you're saying
because
i never hear the numbers like what's the
exact number of the children in these
hospitals exactly the point
yeah i don't know the numbers i i don't
know
and also it's like well we know that
these kids aren't supposed to be
vaccinated and so what are we supposed
to be doing
but i would love to know exactly what
the numbers are because
i always feel like they're not telling
us that's exactly right greg i don't
think there's a story about vaccination
this is a story about reality
the point is the elites like president
obama are not living
like delta variant is this incredibly
scary thing that your language
represented their jessica and when we
make it
vaccinated for our children when we make
decisions for our children and i'm
saying this in all honesty and curiosity
i have to make decisions i want to know
the numbers that greg points out i want
to know what's the hospitalizations and
the mortality
for delta and the rest of covid in the
numbers because what i have seen is
it's less lethal it has less effect on
hospitalizations than the common flu
okay well we do know that it is not a
problem for people who are vaccinated so
if you're watching please get yourself
vaccinated if you're 12 and over we do
know that there are more cases of
children that's being reported in states
like florida
in liberal states as well as california
new york arkansas there was a doctor
there who was pleading for people to get
vaccinated because they are completely
overrun
so i believe the numbers are available i
will text you later when i have them all
let's do it you are awesome all right
ahead carnage and